uh this is absolutely fascinating in the
last 24 hours
we learned about a possible plan for
donald trump to flee the country
to scotland either on the day of or the
day before joe biden's inauguration and
just as quickly we learned
that donald trump isn't going to be
allowed to do that by scottish
authorities
now some of you may know that donald
trump has a much beleaguered golf club
in scotland called turnberry
and speculation has been growing over
the last day day and a half
that donald trump was planning to leave
the united states and head there
after joe biden's inauguration because
of a high amount of surveillance planes
in the area believed to be sort of
laying the groundwork for trump to be
there for some period of time
we also are aware of the scheduling of a
flight arrival there on january 19th of
a u.s military
boeing 757 a plane that donald trump
sometimes
flies on and as quickly as that plan
came together
the scottish first minister nicola
sturgeon has blocked the plan
making it clear that trump coming here
to play golf during a pandemic
that's not essential travel and it's not
going to be allowed
here she is saying it's a no-go i have
no idea what donald trump's travel plans
are um you'll be glad
to know um i hope and expect uh
that as everybody hopes and it's what as
everybody expects not everybody
necessarily will hope that
the travel plan immediately that he has
is to exit the white house
um but beyond that i don't i don't know
but it's
not uh you know we are not uh allowing
people to come into scotland for
uh without an essential purpose right
now and that would apply
to him just as it applies to anybody
else and
coming to play golf is not what i would
consider to be an essential purpose
isn't that just amazing and as usual the
white house
initially put out a non-denial you
you have to read between the lines with
all of this stuff the white house was
initially asked
is trump planning to leave the country
to go to scotland
on the 19th or 20th and uh judd dear the
deputy white house press secretary
said anonymous sources who claim to know
what the president is considering have
no idea
when we have an announcement about
january 20th we will let you know
so as you can see nothing in there
that's a denial
and once it became clear that trump
wouldn't even be allowed in scotland the
white house put out another carefully
worded statement saying
the president has no plans to travel to
scotland
on that date and again that may
technically be true
the plan that may have existed would
likely now no longer exist
because trump's been told you can't come
in uh but in all seriousness
can you imagine a funnier headline than
former president trump denied entry to
scotland and hilariously
if the plan was to go there on january
19th
he'd still be the president president
trump denied entry to scotland
is even funnier and the truth is when
the u.s
sends former presidents to scotland
they're not sending their best
they're sending a grifter con man and
scotland seems to think they need to
shut it down until they can figure out
what the hell is going on
trump actually might have to be in the
united states during joe biden's
inauguration despite his best
efforts and we know that would be really
triggering to donald trump
someone wrote to me saying david he's
not really planning to go to scotland
trump is pretending to be planning to go
to scotland
but he's really going to go to a country
without an extradition treaty to the
united states the u.s and scotland
do have an extradition treaty for
example russia and the u.s do not
china and the u.s do not but i think the
idea falls short because trump wouldn't
be using a military plane
to go somewhere to avoid extradition to
the united states i know people
love talking about trump fleeing to
russia
or wherever wherever else i don't
actually think trump's going to do that
i
i also believe that putin is enough of a
troll
that he probably would also say no to
trump i don't know
i know that the the optics of a former
u.s president fleeing to russia would be
really good propagandistically for
russia
but i also know that putin is a pretty
clever guy and he may even find it
funnier to say no to donald trump but
at the bottom line this is all mere
speculation it's really a story
about once again donald trump's
narcissism
scotland is closed to travel due to the
pandemic
and trump may well have the idea that he
can just fly in and play golf
uh two more weeks my friends we are
almost there what will trump do
i don't know we will know in the next
two weeks much will be revealed very
very soon